welcome to the second of two frankie
visiting fellow lectures
our opportunity to share with the larger
yale community work in progress by
alejandra oliva
before i introduce alejandra i'd like to
say a few words about richard franke
whose generosity has brought alejandra
to yale this year and who died last
friday
rich's contributions to the whitney
humanities center and its programs have
and will continue to lift our spirits
and nourish our minds
he provided both the inspiration and the
endowments for the frankie lectures and
seminars in the humanities the frankie
program in science and humanities and
the frankie visiting fellows program
since
2005 the frankie visiting fellows have
served as catalysts for intellectual
gatherings at the whitney humanities
center
setting their own agendas and presenting
their work to the community
their presence ensures ongoing
interdisciplinary exchange and creative
debate at the whitney in particular and
at yale in general
frankie visiting fellows are an integral
part of the whitney fellowship and this
year i've been especially grateful to
james mccauley and alejandra oliva for
their supportive presence in our
wednesday whitney's humanity center
fellows forums
one final word about rich frankie his
new york times obituary in yesterday's
paper suggests donations to a cause that
was dear to him
support for immigrants and refugees
specifically
integrated refugee and immigration
services in new haven iris
thinking of rich frankie today it brings
me great pleasure to be introducing
someone whose life work centers on
immigration
and who does that work in chicago the
city where the frankies made their home
for most of their lives
i'm delighted then to introduce
alejandra oliva
since she's come to the whitney
alejandra has completed the manuscript
of her much anticipated book river mouth
which her publisher has described
beautifully as quote an urgent reckoning
and re-examination of the humanitarian
crisis we call the american immigration
system
based on her work as a translator for
asylum seekers
her experiences with borders and asylum
include her time following a migrant
caravan and helping families cross over
from tijuana into california which she
described in an award-winning essay at
the border no one can know your name
she can also testify to her work as an
interviewer at an immigrant detention
center attached to a private prison in
the state of mississippi
alejandra brings to all her work her
unique talents as a poet an essayist a
translator a textile artist a theorist
of social justice and language justice
her trajectory is as intentional and
creative as an art as her artwork
after an undergraduate degree at
columbia she began working with the new
sanctuary coalition as a volunteer
interpreter and translator in asylum
clinics she took a master's degree at
the harvard divinity school where she
honed her thinking about social justice
reading oscar romero and valeria
luiselli among others
the day we discussed the poster for her
talk i learned something precious from
her about writing she chose to
illustrate this lecture and you can see
the poster over there
with a work of embroidery she created at
the very worst moment of the lockdown
growing beans in her apartment sitting
in for a long haul she decided to sew
individual beans in a pattern onto the
center of a cloth and if you look very
closely at the photograph you can see
the threads pushed through the beans
with a needle an arduous process
she surrounded the beans with stitched
fans inspired by the work of one of her
favorite mexican textile artists
gabriela martinez ortiz
two textures two substances in harmony
i learned that there's a link for
alejandra between putting words on a
page and stitching
both involve minut attention repeated
gestures
both are born of a mind clearing away
distractions and paying attention to
detail
strength of imagination goes hand in
hand for alejandra oliva with strength
of purpose in the public sphere
she has worked since 2019 as the
communications coordinator for the
national immigrant justice center in
chicago
which provides direct services state and
national advocacy and information to
media who are covering exceptionally
troubled and troubling immigration
policy
we're honored at the whitney to have
given her space to write about this
important work
her lecture is entitled you can't
translate what you can't see
between languages in the u.s immigration
system please join me in welcoming
[Applause]
alejandra all right thank you so so much
alice for that incredibly lovely
introduction and thank you so much to
the whitney humanity center and mr and
mrs richard frankie for giving me this
incredible gift of time and resources to
work on my book
i was so sorry to hear of the passing of
mr frankie may his memory and his legacy
be a blessing
thank you also to all of you that are
here today particularly my family and my
friends who have traveled to be here
i'm incredibly excited to be with you
this afternoon and to talk to you a
little bit about what i've been working
on during my time here
as alice mentioned i'm a translator i
have translated for people who are
filling out asylum applications in the
basement of a church at the u.s mexico
border in tijuana for people who are
waiting to cross
for the lucky few who have emerged on
the other side of harrowing legal
journeys who want to tell a journalist
about what happened to them
i've observed translation happening over
language line a telephonic translation
service in immigration courtrooms in
boston for people appearing in court
over video link i've witnessed the
effects of a lack of language support
for immigrants incarcerated at a prison
owned by core civic in a small town in
mississippi
i've also done translation in the ways
that many of you have experienced it
behind a computer screen with a beloved
or complicated or exciting text open in
one window a word document and another
today i want to talk about both of these
kinds of translation and the way that
they sit next to each other and
influence each other i think it's also
important to note that i haven't really
gotten any translating any training as a
translator or an interpreter nor am i
really an academic i'd like to think
that i've done a fair amount of reading
in the field of translation studies and
that my near daily practice of
translation and interpretation have
really helped me sort through what i've
read define and embrace what feels true
but i also know that i'm not really
engaged with the ways in which the
academic community has been thinking and
talking about translation because of
that i'm not sure how or whether my
project really speaks to more
contemporary conversations about
translation
and translation theory but i'm really
looking forward to your feedback and
questions at the end of the talk
when you're translating you're
constrained by what you can see on the
page if you miss the way the two words
flow sibilantly into one another or you
don't know the meaning of an aphorism
then they don't turn up in the version
of the text you create as you translate
or if they do it's a lucky accident
a sentence carefully crafted for the way
it sounds red aloud falls flat the sky
literally begins to rain cats and dogs
this kind of mistake is invisible to
most readers who will never read both
the original and the translation who
probably don't know enough of the source
language to clock a sloppily translated
axiom however this is also the kind of
mistake that might keep you up at night
as a translator what injustice did you
do to the original what nuances in the
text does your audience have no hope of
grasping because you missed it
something similar happens with the kind
of writing i do my work sits somewhere
between journalism and memoir it's
largely based on my own experiences but
it's bolstered by research by going out
into the field by meeting people by
talking to people
this is to some extent translating the
real world into language i can't really
write something i haven't seen or lived
through i've tried i'm not that good at
it
but i also can't transmit the entirety
of reality to you on the page because i
can't see it all
things by necessity will slip through
the cracks
the possibility for this kind of
misreading or blindness also keeps me up
at night am i doing the stories i tell
justice am i missing the context that
you then will also miss
the stories we tell ourselves the
stories we receive culturally also work
as blinders giving us quick mental
shortcuts to a misconception or letting
us take the way out of the story that
makes us feel the least bad
we prefer to gloss over complexity and
preference of a simple story easy to
tell and understand and respond to these
stories are the equivalent of a word for
word translation they help you get a
general shape down on paper but they're
otherwise they're oddly constructed and
ungainly they're easily misunderstood
and they fall apart under any kind of
closer scrutiny
so much of our current immigration
system the stories in the media the laws
that are written
are meant to be like these word-for-word
translations they supply us with the
easy stories the bad ombres the children
in cages and through them are erased
legions of other stories
thousands of other contexts and
individual lives are papered over or
omitted from the record in favor of the
easy story
it is not hard to be moved to emotion
and action by these stories to anger to
grief or fear to protest but it's just
as important to keep paying attention
even as the big stories run out even as
the narratives unspool into a gray area
the very existence of the immigration
laws we have today is proof of this
our asylum laws specifically were
created to respond to a single story and
for narratives outside of that the aid
we can offer is hamstrung by the laws
we're governed by
our concept of asylum on an
international level is based on ideas
about religious and ethnic persecution
that began during the holocaust
and are narrowly crafted to prevent
another genocide and just that
during the second world war national
immigration quotas based themselves on a
story about other nations overrunning
the united states with floods of
immigrants kept the ms st louis floating
off the coast of the united states full
of german jewish refugees who couldn't
claim a formal kind of immigration
assistance
even as the ship floated close enough to
the shore for the passengers to hear the
music from miami nightclubs even as
americans argued that those on board
should be admitted to the u.s our laws
made no space for the passengers of the
st louis to be granted entry into the
united states
the st louis eventually turned around
and docked again in europe resulting in
the murder of a quarter of its
passengers in nazi death camps
in response to that great horror we have
expanded our story about immigration
once and we need to expand it again
today
to gain asylum you have to convince the
united states government that you have a
credible fear of returning to your home
country because you are or have been
persecuted by your government or an
entity it is unwilling or unable to stop
and that this persecution happened
because you are a member of a particular
social group
a characteristic of yourself that you
are unable or should not be forced to
change your political opinion your
religion your sexuality your ethnicity
your race your gender
our immigration laws and the story that
has inspired them since the 50s keep us
from helping the man from haiti who is
legitimately afraid of returning home
because of rising sea levels and a lack
of local infrastructure
the united nations has predicted that by
2050 between 25 million and a billion
people
worldwide will be climate refugees
displaced by droughts floods fires and
rising seas our immigration laws force
us to treat the man with a possession
charge who has been in the united states
his whole life
differently than the man with a
possession charge who arrived when he
was a year old
both get a few months a couple years in
prison
but at the end of that time we tell one
of them that he has paid his debt to
society and is able to go home
while the other is incarcerated for even
longer separated from his family and
community and ultimately sent to a
strange country he barely knows today's
immigration laws ask us to pretend that
border cities are safe places for people
waiting to enter the country even as the
state department issues travel
advisories warning u.s citizens to stay
away ask us to ignore violence against
people unless it happens under deeply
specific circumstances ask us to
formulaically and easily refuse help to
those who were we to actually listen to
their stories we would extend a hand too
what i'm getting at is this you make a
personal ethics you make laws the same
way you translate a text the same way
you write a book you look at the world
around you and there are things you
notice and there are things you don't
there's the short version of the story
that you're able to receive and a
thousand longer ones you
don't
there's the short sorry if you're lucky
you read the words of other people who
have looked out on the world before you
who have caught other things that you
didn't and you change your mind you
change your actions you start seeing
things you had been blind to before
there are many things that because of
the family the place in society that i
was born into i had the luxury of
learning slowly of learning only
intellectually
and never emotionally until someone who
had learned them the hard way
was kind enough to show me there are
other things other experiences that i
know people to be blind to that i felt
down to my bones
the thing i've been writing and thinking
about for the last five years and more
concretely in the last few months here
at yale is yes immigration yes
translation but it's also reading and
rereading going over passages in your
life poring over someone else's words
until you find your own life irrevocably
altered
today i want to talk to you about the
way this happened in my own life it
starts with translation and it starts
with the two languages i was raised in
what can i tell you about growing up in
two languages what can i tell you about
the way that spanish folded me into my
family the house i grew up in what can i
tell you about how english gave me
access to the world outside my house
allowed me to have a different
vocabulary to talk about who i am
most of my life is conducted in english
that's the language i use to think read
write argue calculate tips chat swear
name myself
but still whenever i hear spanish on the
street especially a strong mexican
spanish a feeling of tenderness of
family springs up inside me this more
than anything means family to me
even though so much of my life happens
in another language this f well of
feeling that spanish uncovers means that
my life lived only in english would be
incomplete
growing up we never really lived
anywhere with big communities of mexican
families or if there were we weren't
really part of them my spanish was not
the spanish of backyard barbecues or
entire weekends spent together with a
herd of other children my age or the
spanish of telling secrets under the
covers at late night sleepovers it was
the spanish of deep inside jokes of my
parents in 1980 slang all cleaned up for
us the spanish of guadalupe pineda
translation was a way the only way in
which spanish became social it allowed
me to reach beyond the boundaries of my
family i marked the beginning of my work
as a translator to january of 2017 the
first week of the trump administration
like a lot of other people i found
myself at odds with everything that week
strange and restless and anxious and so
when a friend offered me the opportunity
to translate for asylum seekers at a
weekly pro se clinic i said yes
immediately
this is how i found myself sitting in a
church basement just off washington
square park with a couple of other
volunteers across the table from a woman
who has only been in the united states
for about three weeks let's call her
myra
i'm not actually going to be telling you
the real names or stories of anyone that
i've talked to
because that's their stories and not
mine but also not giving you a name or a
face to the people that i've met is one
of the reasons that it's so easy to
discard the stories we hear so for now
for this talk meyer exists she has a
name she's a real person i spent an
afternoon with
her story is not dissimilar to those of
many people i've worked with and she's
sitting across the table from me a week
after trump took office
between us was an i-589 form known as
the application for asylum and
withholding of removal and it would be
our job together over the next few hours
to fill out that form and petition the
government so that she could stay in the
united states
the question of where myra will be
allowed to call home is so critical
because the answer is a matter of life
or death
back in honduras where she had lived her
whole life up until a few weeks ago her
brother was shot in front of her and the
guy who did it told her that she would
be next
the asylum application is her best shot
at convincing the us government that her
survival is dependent on her being able
to stay in the country
even though we're here around this table
ready to fill out this application
together all of us which we did not have
to be
myra i'm sure wishes that this
translation we were working on was
unnecessary she would rather her life
had continued on its familiar way her
brother alive her family together in
honduras
i and i assume the other volunteers here
with us wish that meyer's presence in
this country was not to some extent
contingent on the strength of my
translation on the tear-jerkiness or
trauma of meyer's story
the u.s government based on this form
appears to wish myra was not here at all
and yet here we all are myra all of us
volunteers and the us government
collaborators on this translation that
no one really wants
my job sitting across the table from
myra is to let her talk to ask
clarifying questions and see if through
the interview new information can be
shaken loose placed in a chronological
order to form a cohesive narrative with
cause and effect
my job is also to take her words and
carry them across from the spanish she's
spoken her entire life into english the
language spoken by most people in the
united states and critically the
language spoken by the government
officials at the united states
citizenship and immigration services
that will read and judge her application
i'm particularly well suited to the task
if not uniquely so i've spoken both
english and spanish my entire life my
childhood echoing with parental
admonishments to repeat what i'm saying
in espanol
spanish was a language for home for
family for affection and love and
closeness and english was the language
of the outside world of many of the
books i read of school
growing up in a relatively wealthy
family as the us citizen daughter of
mexican immigrants i was given my
languages in the same way i was given my
citizenships as a birthright's
motherlands and mother tongues at once
in my interactions with people that were
working towards both americanness and
english i came to see the outlines of
both as artificial
in context where everything was being
done to divide me politically from the
people i was speaking to it was our
shared language that allowed us to find
shared ground
it was in doing the work the translation
and the interpretation but most
importantly the listening
that my world shifted the political
moral emotional category that
encompassed me and my family and the
people i loved grew and expanded not
just in name or in ideals but in actual
fact
translation for asylum seekers was the
thing that finished transforming my
tongue into a political actor finished
bridging the divide between the spanish
inside my head and the spanish and the
rest of the world spanish the language
of my family allowed me to feel my way
into a kind of intimacy with people i
knew very little about allowed me to be
useful in a way i didn't know how to
imagine
it allowed me to take a thing a language
a vocabulary a way of speaking that was
the province of my safe childhood and to
try to extend it like a protective
mantle over the people who wanted the
same for their own children
the translation with myra was the first
time i was really able to do that but it
also immediately became clear that our
conversation would not be protective it
would not be a matter of safety or care
or love if you're not familiar with the
i-589 form an asylum seeker must fill
out the bulk of the form consists in
detailing whatever traumatic event has
sent someone fleeing from their country
and answering why they believe that
event came looking for them specifically
as each of the forms awful stilted
questions land i watch as myra shrinks
farther and farther back in her chair
her eyes more often seeking out the
corners of the room her sleeve in danger
of being picked apart
i offer tissues even though she's
dry-eyed water even though her voice
doesn't crack a break even though when i
ask she looks at me with a grim set to
her jaw shakes her head no and so we
keep going
as i talk to her i'm also talking to the
two other volunteers around the table
with us explaining to them in my own
voice in my own words what meyer is
telling me so that and they are writing
it down
so the ways in which i'm hurting myra by
asking her to remember do not go to
waste
i take her words and i translate them i
carry across
into i carry them across into the
language of her new country
translation comes from the latin
translators to carry across the word
itself implies an edge a dividing line
to translate means to carry across
languages across borders across cultures
translation is also something we do with
our bodies something that lives in our
blood we move through our mother tongue
into that of a new home we sense the
right word or phrase with the kind of
bodily intuition where shades of meaning
and imprecise logic dwell in his book
translator's turn douglas robinson pass
it's a theory of translation that is
visceral that involves gut feelings and
clammy palms sense residing not in
cognition but in sensation
i have found this to be true
our bodies remember the specific word
flavor of words in two languages the
taste of the edge between two ways of
saying
as the word implies we also use our
bodies to carry meaning from one
language to another
it's impossible not to feel what i'm
translating inside my body impossible
not to carry it with me from a church
basement or a plaza after i hang up the
phone damp and hot from being pressed
next to my ear for an hour
so much of translation and
interpretation requires me to pass
someone else's language through the
first person there i becomes my own
their injuries and experiences enter a
language that for all that i'm trying to
render faithfully as theirs
is in reality only mine
this line of self and not self is like
chalk on a blackboard from far away the
line looks crisp stark easy to
understand but as you approach it as
your nose bumps the dusty slate you
understand that the line is not exactly
unbroken that no matter how much you
erase the particles of the chalk that
were that line still float through the
air
when you translate it becomes clear that
to be entangled with someone's language
is to be entangled in them in their
histories and idiosyncrasies to
translate is to be in community with
someone
this is in part because language is
something we construct together across
countries and continents and centuries
as much as within communities and
conversations there is no expression no
understanding without the other to
express or to understand
when i speak spanish i'm speaking the
language of hernan cortes
juana and yoconda belly cervantes and
marquez it's also my own language the
words taught to me by my mother when i
was just learning to ask for what i
wanted the made-up language composed of
male probisms of mine and my siblings as
we were learning to talk
the borrowed words from english the
patterns of sentences i unknowingly
absorbed from my parents ways of
speaking and made my own
this language is the water i stand in
the well i draw from there are
tributaries feeding my spot in the river
both above and below the earth
this same river a little further
upstream is the one the 17th century
poet nun sur juanines de la cruz drew
from and when i say the word mojed or
the word fei these are words that have
been fundamentally altered by her having
written about them some 300 years ago
the spanish she wrote in turn was
influenced by her time in the viceroys
court as a lady in waiting as it was by
the nautilus she learned from her
mother's household staff as a child
as influenced by the spanish of hernan
cortes who had first come to mexico just
129 years before her birth as by the
language of malinsien the now a woman
who served as his interpreter and the
mother of one of his children
this was the water sarjuana drew from
and what she returned to the river was
forever altered by having passed through
her hands
when i speak or write my words flew out
from my own little eddie to rejoin the
wider stream
my turns of phrase become part of the
spanish that exists in the world just as
sorghumas did able to be picked up and
passed around drawn up to drink from and
to be appropriated by another waiter
in this way language is made up of the
personal and the cumulative each of us
standing in our own space absorbing the
words around us and contributing to the
greater stream
like the waters of the river it's an
inevitable inseparable commingling of
the collective and the individual
language would not work if we could not
share it but the individual impressions
we leave and the baggage we bring with
us on each word we say matter to
we should also talk a little bit about
the baggage the translation in and of
itself brings particularly here in the
west a lot of the earliest questions in
translation studies are ultimately
biblical translation theory
this is why even when you're not
necessarily talking about the word of
god the original is held up as this
bright inviolable light that the
translator must struggle to approach
much less replicate to find the source
of this brightness theorists keep
pointing not just behind the original
text but behind language itself
walter benjamin who was deeply concerned
with the idea of god's language in his
essay the task of the translator
describes a good translation as one that
is transparent so that it quote does not
cover up the original does not block its
light but allows the pure language to
shine upon the original all the more
he gestures not only at the pure
language of babel and the bible but to
the threshold space that translation
occupies the way it needs to both exist
and not
there's a sense in which looking at any
original in the light of divine
origination makes total sense the
creation of any text is a miracle of
individuation of reference and
self-reference of idiosyncratic
experiences
just as miraculous as the idea of an
individual consciousness
when you're translating literary text
there's a kind of slow awareness of this
as you find your sentences unfurling
along paths that are not your usual a
different understanding of the creator
of the text when you translate you
become aware that this author your
author uses the word cuerpo the word
casa the word tierra like no one ever
has or will again
you also realize that you can only ever
know a part of it you can only skim the
surface of their meaning the dizzying
individuality of any single writer or
mind multiplied by all the possible
writers and minds or even your own as
you read or translate unfold into a
world that feels as intricate as god's
fingerprint
my investment in this idea however stops
short when i think of my other source
texts which are not usually the product
of slow mornings sitting at your desk or
even the stress and pressure of looming
deadlines but rather the product of
extreme violence and fear created not to
serve a creative desire but rather to
fill a bureaucrat's form
i don't like the implication that
there's something holy about suffering
that's present in so much of christian
philosophy and often gets carried over
into translation theory i hate the idea
that there's a pure and shining light at
the back of any of the pain i've borne
witness to
none of it feels like what i want god to
be i don't want to honor the original
don't want to revere it like i might the
words from god's mouth
on the other hand i also don't want to
mutilate the stories i'm given like i do
every time i fill out an asylum
application it feels sacrilegious to cut
up someone's life in the interest of the
government because there's something of
value in someone's story something that
deserves careful treatment deserves to
be honored and respected and not prised
out with priors and smashed up
this something isn't about the divinity
or the forward donation of any story or
the sacredness of the idea of stories in
general or about the beauty of suffering
but because the people telling them are
viscerally embodiedly human
as i'm reminded with every tissue or
glass of water these stories are
important because the person sitting in
front of me and i share the fragility of
our flesh and are entrusted to one
another because of the thinness of our
skins the delicate workings of our
insides
at the same time our bodies are not
enough
the asylum application is a skeleton
that like the worst b-movie cliche longs
for a body
the asylum system is hungry for bodies
bodies to suffer bodies to fill up beds
in for-profit detention centers bodies
to work in the fields and factories and
behind the scenes of everything all the
while rejecting their humanity
the i-589 pretends to care about
biography asks for a narrative in a
specific person's voice but in reality
is only concerned with the violence on
the body glancing off anything deeper
than the skin
a bad translation does the same work it
lives on the surface of the text it's
concerned with the physical shape the
surface meaning whatever reflection
momentarily blinds you
a good translation drives somewhere to
the beating heart of a text you can only
translate what you can see and if all
that is visible to you as a body if all
that is presented is the surface then
there's something about the human that's
still invisible to you to the government
to the immigration judge and his
chambers and the cbp patrolmen in his
truck
the people i translate for are survivors
among generations of the sabaresidos the
farmers with land not yet seized or made
barren by multinational corporations the
people who are not left to die in the
desert or dumped into mass graves in the
sea or corralled into camps to die of
neglect the campesino no one bothered to
bribe
the united states has been deeply
involved in central and south america
for decades behind every revolution
every uprising and coup of the 20th
century there were cia agents or
congressmen making colonial decisions to
stop the spread of communism
or more commonly to protect u.s
investments and corporations
the translation i take part in is the
migorous form of reparations and has
more to do with the cia agents and the
congressman than the utopian promise
that more contemporary translators make
for us
like the united states which welcomed
european immigrants as low-level workers
with a plea for the world's tired and
hungry which bills itself is a great
melting pot with fine words about the
equality of all men
translation likes to describe itself as
a diplomat bridging cultures or as a
bridge itself spanning the rio grande
the kind of thing that can transcend
borders but ignoring the ways that power
can thrum through and across that bridge
the way a diplomat always always has his
own nation's best interests at heart you
become complicit in this power
when i translate for an asylum seeker
like mayra i like to think i'm working
against the powers that be but the truth
is i'm filling out the form i'm making
people findable searchable
cross-indexable for a government that
has proven time and time again that the
only way in which it cares about these
lives is it says resources to be
extracted to exhaustion
i don't know how else to help i don't
know if i'm brave or smart or strong
enough to find another way to wipe away
the fear of separation the fear of
return to remake the world into the
place it needs to be to make sure
everyone is safe i don't even know if
bravery or smarts or strength on an
individual or an even collective level
are capable of fixing this problem
instead what i have is this government
form and a little while to spend across
the table from myra
and the ability to make her feel heard
even if i know this application might
not be enough
years later when i started working more
closely with actual immigration
attorneys rather than just volunteers i
found out that they actually call the
i-589 on its own a skeleton application
just the bare bones when a lawyer
actually helps someone apply for asylum
something that happens in less than four
and ten people applying from outside the
detention center and for even fewer
people applying from inside
the skeleton is in flesh
you add affidavits expert witness
testimonies reports from forensic
pathologies who are able to examine
clients living bodies fat files of
reporting on what's called country
conditions a fully completed asylum
application usually runs somewhere
between 300 and 500 pages solid bricks
of paperwork that are stacked up by like
a defensive wall when someone goes into
court
we in the pro se clinic were turning in
the 12 flimsy pages of the application
alone this in itself was a strategy it
allowed myra to have an application in
prior to the one-year filing deadline
it gave her extra time to find an
attorney to find another means of
protection to ensure that she's at least
got that pending asylum application that
paperwork in as a mean for safeguarding
against deportation for the years it
will take for that application to wind
through the system
the text that i end up producing for
that form is by necessity skeletal it's
a bone shard in the desert the boxes
provided for answers to the questions
asked by the i-589 are small and the
attorneys who review our files don't
recommend using the overflow space
provided
so we're restricted to 150 words per
answer clipped and factual describing
the things that have left a mark on a
single body but never what it is like to
live inside that body
asylum translation is less like building
a bridge and more like the translation
of saintly relics
when a saint is canonized they are
brought up out of their resting place
usually somewhere where they lived and
grew up and did their holy works
and instead brought to a place that is
the center of power when constantinople
for example became the center of the
christian world a flock of holy bones
was translated there from the
surrounding areas this legitimated the
holiness of the tibia of saintly acadia
the forest full of splinters of the holy
cross the skull of saint cordula but it
also gave holiness and legitimacy to the
church in constantinople marking it as
holy for being able to gather holiness
to itself
when saints bones enter a church they're
gilded and boxed up removed from their
context of a grave of a living person
somewhere in a community
and instead re-contextualized and
presented alongside the calcified hey
geographies as proof of the church's
power
you don't know actually who saintly
acadia or st cordula are or who they
were or what they did or how they died
all you know are their bones their
holiness their presence proof that the
church is worth dying for
the translation of bones serves the
church and not the stories of those
interred
the us government is not the catholic
church but it does require asylum
seekers to be saints it gathers their
stories to itself forces them to be
translated in language and in fact given
that they don't accept anything other
than paper files something which has
continued to be true through the
pandemic
uh mailed into their headquarters into
their own language and space literally
the power here only moves in one
direction and everything done by asylum
seekers every translation done by them
and their allies serves only the reader
the united states government
the text the presentation of it the
imprisonment of it within the forms
boxes away from the messiness of a real
life and into the beats of a known and
understood hagiography a quiet and
virtuous life shattered by a single act
of explicitly politically motivated
violence an escape by night a plea for
safety these are meant not at all as an
expression of the person telling the
story and entirely to satisfy the entity
processing it
if i do my job right if in those 150
words i succeed as a translator what the
asylum seeker i'm working with gets is a
grudging acceptance of their humanity a
big official rubber stamp that says that
their suffering matters but not much
else does about the ways in which they
have stayed alive or lived at all just
the suffering
a lawyer i worked with at the clinic
called it bureaucratic violence the
carrying across of people out of their
own words their own language the
mutilation of the stories they tell
a violence i participated in even if it
was as gentle as i could make it
there was however one other way in which
the translation i was doing was skeletal
when you're doing literary translation
again it's common to talk about the ways
that you're subsumed enveloped given
over to the shape of someone else's
language
a literary translation project involves
making yourself porous to the text
allowing it into you and allowing
yourself into it all reading all
interactions really involve this kind of
cross-pollination but translation also
asks and answers a different question
when you're translating you're giving
over room in your brain days of your one
single life to the careful minute study
of someone else's work in order that
others might have the privilege of
encountering it
you're not only recognizing that your
voice isn't the only the most important
one but you're sinking precious hours
into that belief
there's also a return though in making
yourself porous you also make yourself
expansive you're allowed to reach beyond
yourself
this is both different and not when i'm
translating for asylum seekers even as
i'm translating their stories i'm
passing every word they say through my
own first person feeling an echo of what
they're telling me in my own self
their stories are often ones of violence
against their bodies stories that pass
through me as they pass through language
i can catalog on my own body the places
where people have shown me their scars
turning me into a mirror cigarette burns
on the back of a carefully manicured
hand the aftermath of a surgery that was
itself the aftermath of a stabbing
someone's chest and the softness of
their belly crisscrossed with ropes of
scar and the punctums of stitches on
either side
old old bullet scars cleanly through
both ankles
an unset broken leg and the weight on my
shoulder of the man who used me as a
crutch for a short walk
i don't know in my body what it's like
to be hurt in these ways but i carry a
record with me anyway because it's
impossible not to
it's very much on vogue right now to
talk about second-hand trauma something
common among social workers and emts and
anyone else whose job involves stepping
into the worst day in people's lives
as a shadow of knowledge that wraps
around you when you have come to know
through observation the depths of
cruelty that exist in the world
secondhand trauma is complex it works in
many of the same ways that firsthand
trauma does your brain gets rewired in
the same ways your physiological
responses are the same to it
however secondhand trauma also carries
the shame of safety you're aware that
you live removed from the suffering
itself that your reactions are outsized
for someone who basically has just heard
about the pain that you're protected
even if your physiological responses
don't recognize that
why should i find myself crying on the
train rides back home why does someone's
story linger with me take up space in my
brain night after night
nothing had after all really happened to
me
here's where secondhand trauma does
differ from first though i give it time
just a little a matter of weeks or
months and the howling rage stops the
winds die down
it gets quiet enough for me to work to
put words to the things that i saw and
felt to find the way to bring other
people into what i'm feeling
when i translate i try to make myself
invisible in a sense i don't exist when
i take up the weight of someone else's
story by translating it the thing i
carry is a ghost and the teller is no
lighter for the mere fact of me carrying
the story alongside them
it's in feeling the weight of the story
that i can transmit it to you also which
is why i try
and why i try to erase myself in the
process so that you might read someone's
words that i have translated and be
reminded of your mother or your aunt or
your sister
your neighbors and friends forgetting
the step in the middle
i aim to become invisible because then
this asylum seeker is speaking directly
to you and you have no choice but to
listen
when i'm writing though working on this
book or on a press release or a client
profile for my day job for the speech
this is when i have a different goal
you for better or worse recognize me as
one of your own we share experiences a
language a way of reading or thinking
about the world that means that i've
been invited here to work and give a
talk at yale but i've also however
briefly and not experientially had my
foot in another world which is the world
that i'm here to translate for you
this trauma translation my weaker ghost
version of the original thing that i
witnessed i'm hoping it works like a
real translation
in the same way that translating a text
brings it to a new audience i want my
work to bring a reality that was
previously invisible and illegible to
light
i'm hoping it builds a bridge to greater
understanding or rather a bridge across
the gaps when you realize that like me
you understand so very little of
anything
i hope it's clear that what i'm giving
you is not cannot actually be the real
thing i couldn't even hold the real
thing myself i felt it slipped through
my fingers as i tried
it's far from walter benjamin's ideal of
an invisible translator but i'm doing
the only thing i can i'm making myself
visible i'm taking your hand and walking
you through it pointing out the places
where i've left things out or omitted
details critiquing my own translating as
we go
i can't go back to the person i was
before that church basement in new york
before tijuana before the boston
courtroom or the prison along the
mississippi i can't un-become my
parent's daughter i can't unlearn
spanish or teach my unteach myself
english and so i'm left to return to
these things and places over and over
to draw strength from them to see the
world more clearly to think of them not
as the facts of a biography but as tools
with which to dismantle walls tools with
which to fling open the doors and beckon
people in
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm wondering you know you've worked on
a lot of different kinds of translation
are there kinds of translation that
you haven't worked on that you would
really like to explore or things sort of
on your radar that you know maybe you've
worked on privately that you hope to
maybe bring to your professional side i
know that you
have a lot of different directions for
translation that you work on yeah um i
have done a fair amount of literary
translation kind of on my own but
haven't had a ton published i do have a
book
with fordham university press that i got
to collaborate with uh
rachel buff who is an immigration
historian at the university of milwaukee
and the book is called a is for asylum
seeker and it's actually a bilingual
edition which is
really great but um beyond that i
haven't really gotten to do a ton of
literary translation that's been like
published and edited and that i've
really got to like
be forced to bring all the way to
completion and so i
that's something that i really would
like to do more of
um thank you so much for that that was a
really beautiful and very stimulating
talk um i realize um some members of the
audience may be more versed in all this
literature than i am but i was just
curious if you could explain a little
bit more
the connection you described between um
kind of modern translation theory and
literature and christian conceptions of
suffering and the connection between
those two and
uh i found that fascinating yeah yeah so
i think a lot of times when you are
looking at really early
um translation theory like a lot of the
really like saint jerome who was the
first guy to translate the bible into
latin in its entirety
um you're really seeing a lot of things
that are struggling with like how can we
take this
this text that we recognize as being
completely divine completely inviolable
and then translate it like is that not
removing it from its sanctity is it not
like carrying it away from that in a lot
of the same ways that we talk about
translations as being like less correct
versions of the original text or sort of
adulterated versions uh there's a quote
i think from cervantes who describes
a translation as the back of a
back of an embroidery actually and like
showing all the seams and the ugly sides
um
and so
when you are
sort of referring to the original in
this like inviolable light because it's
divine because it's perfect even when
you're talking about something other
than a than a scriptural text
you're still sort of giving it this
this authority and this this divinity
that gets really complicated and gets
really muddy when what you're talking
about is
someone's account of suffering that was
sort of extracted from them unwillingly
in order so that they might fill out
this form and i think that christian
scripture especially is really
there's a lot of emphasis on suffering
in particular being pure and being
divine and being one of the ways that we
attain holiness like just through like
the christ story alone is a
pretty clear example of that um and so
when you kind of lay those things
together things get really really muddy
if you're looking at this suffering as
holy when
we should really be regarding it as
anything but
is this on
um i wondered whether the words that you
just shared with us uh your speech today
is in the book that's coming out
because i want to share it with some
other interpreters that i know oh
wonderful and i don't know if it's
separate or in the book um it's in the
book but i was kind of copying and
pasting a lot from different sections of
the book there's some things in here
that don't appear in the book like the
book is
it's a venn diagram that's very closely
overlapped but there's still some stuff
outside of it but um i think this is
going to be on youtube later so
yeah
hi thank you so much for coming and
speaking with us
you cited earlier um walter benjamin's
the test the translator and and one of
his core arguments in that text is that
it's not just merely
that the translator's role is to
translate um a work from a language a to
language b but that that act of
translation in fact
changes
both those languages and the work itself
yeah
and i actually i'm a student at the law
school and i recently had the
opportunity to do intake interviews for
asylum seekers and so i'm curious kind
of
uh having kind of gone through that
translation process myself in a smaller
form
what is your process of translation as
well as navigating your ethical
obligations the translator when you're
trying to take what these tren what
these um clients
of yours are trying to share with you
and as you translate that and and change
it into a
in a separate language and as well into
the box that you said you know the box
that basically the us government wants
you to be able to fit their narrative in
and also try and create a compelling
narrative for the government
yeah so this was something that i really
struggled with and i still really
struggle with as i'm
in my day job i still i am the
communications coordinator for the
national immigrant justice center i end
up interviewing a lot of people and
while they get to tell someone expanded
stories
of and about themselves for things like
the media and stuff there's still always
sensitivities around the case that we
want to be like okay i know this feels
important for you but you cannot share
this in a wider venue in case it impacts
your case or
people are going to read this in a
different way than what you are wanting
to share about yourself and then it's
it's also really hard to like actually
get someone's
like full informed consent to do the
kind of like translation and
storytelling that you're doing because
you're like
this is what i need from you this is
what the us government needs from you
and i know that like what feels
important to you about your story is
maybe not the same things as what this
other entity feels is important and so
the best answer the best workaround i've
found is to just read back like
re-translate whatever i've come up with
back into spanish for them and be like
okay here's what i have for you i know
it's not going to say the whole thing i
know it's not
how you would tell your story because
i've heard you tell your story and this
is not how you tell it but
i'm going to give you back what i've
done and like tell me if there's
something that you want to change
keeping in mind that we have all of
these bullet points that we need to sort
of hit in order to make this the
strongest case that we can for you
and so it's
just about like talking back and forth
as much as possible and being like
here's what i'm hearing from you here's
what i need to share with the government
here's what the government is going to
know about you eventually or what this
journalist is going to know or what we
can share with this journalist and what
would be better if we don't talk to you
about them or whatever is going on
yeah i want to continue on that because
as you were speaking there was this
incredible
suspense you created in your talk and i
was imagining the form in my mind i mean
i could see the paper and i was
imagining
how in the world you know how miriam's
story came out
and i started thinking about narrative
and about restraint
and the kind of cons restraint you have
to use i mean you've answered it a
little but i guess
what i wonder is
say in your book are you going to
include some of those forms
oh that's a good question i don't
currently have any in there right now i
do have some of the conversations that i
was describing of like okay i'm gonna
read you your story back or like
let's have this conversation about
what's going on and like
there are also all different kinds of
ways that people like respond to having
to tell this story like i've sat there
with people who are just telling joke
after joke after joke of like horrifying
things that are happening to them i've
heard of people who like
just stare down with their hands like do
a monotone like i'm going to get this
all out it's going to come out once and
that's it no questions
we're done here uh
i've had people who cry through the
whole thing like there's just such a
variety of of ways that people encounter
this questioning
that again you're like i want to be able
to take this and like show the
government like this person is
so altered by having passed through this
and like their storytelling is so
altered by having gone through this
experience and there's just no way to
get that across
and some people end up eventually
getting to go to court and having their
hearing and being able to testify on
their own behalf but that's pretty rare
yeah it's it's it's heartbreaking that
there's no room for storytelling and yet
you need to move somebody somebody on
the other end is reading and being moved
yeah reading between the lines yeah
thank you
thank you so much for sharing this story
with us i am wondering um where your
relationship ends with each of these
clients does it stop after they fill out
this form or do you continue to help
them through their process and get
updates on whether their application was
approved or not um that really depends
on like what
what i'm working on them with so like
when i was working at the pro se clinic
it was very much like have your
paperwork go file it like we were not
attorneys we were not really qualified
to help them through any of the other
stages of the process and so every once
in a while someone would come back and
be like this happened or like this is
going on i do have a lot more contact
with the folks that i work with now at
the national immigrant justice center
because i do work with a lot of
attorneys who
like there have been times i actually
got to there's an ap story about this
that i did the translation for but we
had a client named
alex who had been in detention for a
really really long time uh he was a gay
man and he had been
like the the guards there were just kind
of pushing him around and being really
mean to him and he
i said that they were gonna let him go
and they didn't and uh
like there was all this like push-pull
going on with that and then
there got to a point where he was like
i'm done i want to talk to a reporter
let's get this set up and so i was able
to like work on interpreting through
that with him and then like
a couple months ago actually he got out
and you know got reunited with his
boyfriend he's like living very happily
and so like it's very occasionally that
i get to like hear the end point of
someone's story but like
especially now that i'm working with a
legal aid organization
very often they are good endings to
stories and that that's really really
nice
i think we're set oh haley's coming back
um so i know the book that you're
working on right now is coming out and
i'm curious in terms of
how much of that includes
sort of your experience with immigration
versus translation theory versus and you
touched on some of the sort of like
christianity roots of of
translation and sort of how do you
how do you balance what you know how
much you include of those pieces
um by having a very good editor
i gotta say that a lot of my early
drafts are like pretty heavily lopsided
in one direction or another and they're
like okay hold on you have to bring this
other thread back or
you have to
talk about this a little more
i also
know that i know a lot about this stuff
but sometimes forget that other people
don't and so i've also i am lucky enough
to work with a really fantastic agent
who was like
i don't know what this means you need to
explain you know what a credible fear
interview is a little better or
something like that and so i've been
really really lucky to work with other
people who've been fantastic readers and
asking me like good questions to make
sure that everything's
well balanced because that's not always
my first impulse
[Music]
well we wish you just huge success thank
you
thank you again for sharing
your story and the story of your clients
thank you so much
[Applause]
you